uh nice to see both of you I am a fan of
both of your work if someone has not
seen besides Transformers obviously they
should go see it but if someone has not
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why I mean I'ma say swarm
even though they might be scared of me
after it's okay
because because
um you know I started in theater and in
school when I graduated I decided to
write a one on Michelle because I've
heard and I play multiple characters and
I didn't think that on a series I would
get a similar opportunity to play
multiple characters she's different
pretty much in every episode especially
the last one I'm not going to spoil it
but it was it was really exciting
exciting and it showed versatility that
was my dream when I first started
wanting to act I want to show
versatility and I feel like it shows and
then they go watch this and then it's
like oh it's completely different
totally in the heights I would say you
know I got to really show a lot of sides
in that versatility I guess
she takes my asses all the time so
[Laughter]
um yeah you know just you know just
different yeah shape-shifting in in the
heights yeah so yeah that's I used to
sing the songs on the set of
Transformers anytime I saw him I'd be
like saying something that he was
singing with me and I was like oh my God
fangirl I'm curious what for both of you
this is a huge production and I'm what
surprised you about making a film like
on this scale with this scope because
you know you're you're filming it so far
like you know a few years ago and you
have to wait to have it come out yeah
what was surprising for me was that it
was really intimate uh a lot of times
that obviously there's no robot so this
lessons me and Anthony acting to air you
know and it's just it was like it felt
like a small it felt like a small
project even though it was so big yeah I
mean I haven't seen them up today I'm
watching the movie for the first time so
I'm I'm you know I think the the you
know I think but at least seeing seeing
the the trailer and working in ADR and
seeing like what Pete did especially
with Mirage like
it's just you're in this bubble a little
bit when we're shooting and you would
you know if if I'm not shooting with dom
or if I'm not shooting with Toby
I'm shooting with nobody you know so I'm
just like talking to the air and doing
these emotional scenes I mean like that
there's a scene with Mirage that's super
emotional and I'm like hitting Mirage on
the chest and I'm like rushing like
there was like when we're shooting it it
was one of the grips just had a piece of
cardboard that he's just standing over
me and I'm doing this emotional scene
and I'm just hitting this piece of
cardboard that this guy is holding over
me so uh shout out shout out to our crew
they were amazing but yeah like it's
some so it's just really seeing the the
the the movie after and seeing the
characters and how they built out and
looking at them you know like even when
I look at the poster I'm like dang
Primal looks crazy you know seeing all
of that it's really cool you're going to
be very happy when you see the movie
thanks like uh the CGI looks fantastic
it really it really does but I wanna uh
one of the things that's like really
cool in the film is the stuff in Peru
um it adds so much because you guys
actually went there can you talk about
filming there and um you know uh because
it's it's I don't they've ever filmed
where you guys were I was special it was
really special you know Peru Peru like
as soon as we got there I knew it was
going to be like different man we got
there and and and uh in Machu Picchu
where we were staying at our hotel they
had like this big yard so this the
shaman came and and and me and Don we
went out there with with like Lorenzo
and Steven and the shaman like blessed
our production and bless the time that
we were gonna have there and it just
felt almost like
it almost felt like we weren't like not
that we were alone but it felt like the
country was behind us now
he gave us some it wasn't there was a
government official yeah
celebrate us for filming there yeah but
it was special man like no I don't I
think we were one of the first people to
ever shoot on Machu Picchu like we went
to the Jungle we shot in terrapoto for
like two weeks the heat was crazy but
some some of the most beautiful shots
you'll ever see Stephen captured like we
were really not good like it's real yeah
no I'm saying it it adds a lot and also
I think you used some great drone shots
in the movie so it really adds so I'm
I'm very curious what sequence in the
film did you guys think was going to be
kind of easy and ended up being a huge
pain in the ass no
that's the one that I was falling asleep
in for me I literally was looking at Dom
of course I am giving him my emotional
things that he's
supposed to be that boring
yeah like I'm talking about we in this
plane at like three in the morning like
we're doing this overnight scene and I'm
just looking at her and she's well this
was about my dad yeah yeah were you
telling me a story about your dad I'm
literally looking at her like this
so when you see that just know I was
emoted to a sleeping answer yeah yeah
I'm not even gonna lie we have to
reshoot that scene I'm gonna have to
research that scene uh so that's just
seeing that on paper I thought was gonna
be a walking apart
one of the hardest snakes on this entire
film